you bought your house recently for
$200,000 and the way that you were able
to pay $200,000 is you were able to put
25% down so you made a $50,000
downpayment $50,000 down payment and the
balance the other 75% you borrowed from
the bank so 150,000 $150,000 loan loan
from the bank and you pay it off with
your monthly payments that include
paying down the loan and the interest
now something happened in your life
maybe unfortunately you lost your job or
your spouse lost their job or maybe you
just overestimated your ability to pay
off your your mortgage payments and so
you're having difficulty making them and
we're at effect frankly you can't make
your mortgage payments anymore so in
this situation you have a couple of
options to for you one option is you can
try to sell the house so some type of a
sale or the other option is you could
essentially give the house back to the
bank and that will call foreclosure in
another video we'll go more in depth of
what happens in foreclosure but the bank
is going to get the property try to
oxygen it off it can option it off and
the bank will own the property and then
maybe they'll try to sell it at a later
date and this is not a good option for
you this will kill this will kill your
credit which will make it very hard for
you to get a loan and really have any
type of loan but especially a mortgage
loan any time in the near future really
over the next several or many years so
you say okay I want to do I want to do
the sale option now unfortunately for
you the housing market has deflated
dramatically and so when you talk to a
realtor you say the realtor figures out
well look after all is said and done I
mean you try to sell it for more than
your loan amount but you're not able to
you're getting really low offers low the
offers are like a hundred twenty
thousand one hundred thirty thousand and
so when you really sit with the realtor
and you think about what the market is
willing to pay for your house you
realize that the most you're going to
get for your house after you pay the
real estate Commission's and all of the
other things that are involved when you
sell a house you could get maybe one
hundred twenty thousand one hundred
twenty thousand four for the house and
let's say you still owe pretty close to
one hundred fifty thousand and a loan
from the bank your loan might have even
met an interest-only loan but even after
a year or two you're probably not going
to pay down the balance of your loan
too much it might be like a hundred
forty thousand one hundred forty five
thousand and you're only able to get a
hundred twenty thousand for the house so
what do you do you don't want to go to
the situation where you sell the house
for 120 thousand
you still owe 150 thousand on the loan
and so you're still going to have to pay
thirty thousand dollars for a house that
you don't even have anymore
so what do you do well one option and
this is not always going to be an option
is to go to your bank and say can I do a
short sale can I do a short sale and a
short sale is essentially selling the
house for less than you own the loan so
let me write this down
selling selling for less than what you
owe what less than what you owe and the
bank doesn't have to but the bank might
will one the bank would have to agree to
this short sale because their loan is
secured by this property that you're
selling and in most cases the reason why
you would want to do the short sale is
that the bank may forgive the balance of
the loan so you try to convince bank to
forgive convince convince bank to
forgive the balance so for example you
could go to the bank you say look I lost
my job we're having trouble paying for
this house now I can only after paying
real estate commissions and all the rest
I can only get 120 thousand for this
house I know that I owe you 150 thousand
can you forgive the extra thirty
thousand at i/o and the bank might
choose to do that now even in this
situation you have to be very very very
very careful and this has to be
negotiated with the bank and all the
rest is because the bank could still
report you to credit agencies report
report to credit agencies which is
really not going to be a whole lot
better than
foreclosure so when part of this
negotiation process and the bank isn't
under no obligation to either forgive
your loan and let you go forth with that
short sale and they're under no
obligation to hype - I would say hide it
but to not talk to the credit agencies
but part of that negotiation you should
try to convince them where you would
ideally try to convince them not to
report it to the credit agencies the
other issue with a short sale and this
is something that few people think about
is when you have let's say in this case
$30,000 forgiven 30k forgiven the IRS
might consider that to be income so you
might have to pay income tax income tax
on this right over here and people
always ask me wait if someone forgives
alone why is that considered income and
the best way to think about is if the
IRS did not consider that income it'd be
huge loophole and how someone could
compensate someone if I wanted to pay
someone I could I could give them so
this is me this is the person that I'm
trying to pay I could give them a loan I
could give them let's say I could give
them $100,000 $100,000 loan and then I
could forgive the loan and so it would
essentially be I gave them $100,000
maybe to do some work for me would be a
transfer of money by giving a loan and
then keep forgiving over and over and
over it would be completely identical to
giving someone a gift which is taxed or
giving someone some type of income so a
short sale you're not always going to be
able to do it in this scenario but if
your house is selling less than the
value of the loan you might be able to
negotiate with the bank to allow you to
sell the house for less than the value
of the loan the bank's other option is
that you're they're going to have to go
into some type of foreclosure proceeding
and take ownership of the house which is
expensive for the bank as well but the
keys here are even if the bank is
willing to let you sell the house for
less than the loan amount you really the
the owner really needs to make sure that
the bank is willing to forgive the
balance and ideally not report to credit
agencies